from the time I was a
kid there's certain characters certain
things that you've seen that have an
impact on you that stay with
[Music]
[Applause]
you and Godzilla was one of
[Music]
them it's an honor to be
invited by our friends and collaborators
at too and at legendary to play in this
monster
there is a legacy that goes back 70
years that we want to be respectful of
so we have to honor everything and
maintain consistency and the thing that
was exciting was to tell a human scaled
story on a monster scaled stage Chambers
deep in the Bedrock there's something
down
there oh my God go go go the movies are
so Grand and epic and with a show like
this we get the luxury to explore it in
10 episodes which means more detail more
drama it's really exciting hit the gas
doc there's two timelines happening in
this show one in the ' 50s and one in
the modern era and the present day
characters discovered that they're part
of this interconnected Legacy did our
dad really work for Monarch it is your
family business it's the family curse my
son whyatt and I were're playing the
same person we go from his period of
time back in the ' 50s to modern day we
had been asked to be in the same movie
usually as Father and Son but the idea
of playing the same person has artistic
element to it that Drew us to it things
I do for Monarch wouldn't have made it
this far without you every time I think
we're searching for D turns out there's
some Monarch business in the way I'm
sorry everything is Tangled Up together
but yes all these roads lead to one
place this crew that we follow in the
present day are just as new to the world
as a new viewer might be welcome to
Monarch sorry they're not scientists and
superheroes they are regular people
everything is new and insane every time
you go to locations in the show it's a
completely different world we shot on a
glacier
move we shot in the desert we went to
Tokyo just
amazing it's the most rewarding
experience to be part of something this
cool this
big I feel like the show we all set out
to do was going to be epic and adventure
but all of the underlying feelings are
there too this changes
everything
on the audience who loves the monster
verse will see a world they recognize
and feel it's been honored and new fans
will watch this and go wow this is the
story that I'm being drawn into this is
a height of entertainment it has action
and excitement and all these monsters
are pretty gnarly I'll say
that